lui patrick balkany wii présente elle
isabelle du même nom unis par les liens
du mariage depuis 1976 par la politique
et les scandales à répétition le jeune
loup du rpr est élu maire de levallois
perret en 1983 s'empara logique et nomme
aussitôt madame à la direction de la
communication avant qu'elle ne s'occupe
de l'animation de la ville nous allons
avoir serré mais placent la place de
verdun sur 5000 mètres carrés papeete
tahiti la polynésie elle valoir
mais la première fois qu'ils
apparaissent tous les deux dans un même
reportage en 1995 c'est pour leurs
premiers démêlés avec la justice
c'est pour l'utilisation d'employés
municipaux à des fins personnelles que
les époux balkany comparaîtront devant
le tribunal correctionnel
trois agents employés par le maire pour
entretenir deux résidences du couple et
désaveu rapide en 1996 patrick balkany
et condamné quinze mois de sursis 200
mille francs d'amendé et deux ans
d'inéligibilité déchets toujours reçu
chez moi des chefs d'entreprise des gens
qui ont amené de la richesse dans la
commune et j'avais besoin d'être aidés
en 2001 la sphère reste un caillou dans
la chaussure de patrick balkany et
l'egypte à nouveau élu à nouveau il est
contesté par l'opposition
quand on vous enlève votre permis de
conduire pendant un mois
et bien quand on vous le rend vous
pouvez conduire et ben il en va de même
pour une inéligibilité
elle a été deux ans elle est pas pour la
vie patrick balkany est encore
aujourd'hui maire de levallois perret et
isabelle balkany sa première adjointe
malgré la dizaine d'affaires qui les ont
concerné bon nombre de levalloisien leur
apportent leurs soutiens pas le cas
n'est qu'en foot l'a fait depuis 2014
une affaire fragilise peu à peu le
couple il s'agit des villas des balkany
celle de saint martin d'abord
déclarer au fisc par les blues s'étaient
manifestement une erreur elle est
décidée à y faire face et elle est
décidée à en assumer les conséquences
l' affaire concerne désormais plusieurs
demeures à l'étranger qui ont valu des
revenus occultes au couple patrick
balkany est jugé pour blanchiment de
fraude fiscale aggravés corruption
passive et prise illégale d'intérêt
quant à isabelle balkany
elle est visée pour blanchiment de
fraude fiscale aggravé et fausses
déclarations
[Musique]